joining us here from the ringer once
again is our good friend fresh back from
his summer at the Jersey Shore where it
was remarkable that you had your own
beach for one day I did not go that was
right that was not me I was not that was
not the great governor of the state of
New Jersey the great estate of major
great state of New Jersey uh remarkable
well I could say he is remarkable the
only thing I will say only a home in
this great state of New Jersey at least
he hasn't raised my property taxes which
most every governor does okay so I leave
on that there you go
other than that it's all been downhill
good to see you sir good to be here yeah
and your your your piece on on how to
beat the Patriots I want to talk about
that I've got a coal hole couple of
segments with you here certainly as we
start with you in the Honda inside a
report here on the Rich Eisen show with
Lambeau what uh what can you tell us
about bortles
and the Jaguars which is the topic du
jour I know you've been head scratching
over the fact that they picked up his
option yeah yes I was on your I was on
that oh when it happened and I mean they
had to carry me out of here I went to
rehab immediately after I mean it was
like remarkable like who's your
competition for Blake bortles like what
could who is coming after him 19 million
and if he gets hurt now they can't walk
away from it I mean this happened rg3 in
Washington what they had a cinammon
season to make sure that they could walk
away exactly so if he goes out there and
he plays but look you know I've learned
this in the NFL you know when you make a
mistake you got to own up to it I've
made them we all make them everybody
make some guys in the Hall of Fame
whether it's Bill Polian who's been a
general manager or George Young would
they all make all of us make mistakes
there's it's when you don't own up to it
and David Caldwell just refuses to have
any objectivity with this well what's
wrong with him what's wrong with bortles
Boros has know about a piece for the
wringer back in April about having seven
qualities off the field that you have to
have and one of them is when your mama
lifts you from the crib you either have
it or you don't and you have that
instinct that innate ability to let the
ball go you know we when you played in
Staten Island and I played in Ocean City
I would throw you know we would go out
for routes and the quarterback would see
you open Heathrow with you right well
that don't work in pro football
you got to anticipate the guy being open
you got to anticipate the throw
there's an anticipation he don't have it
he's gotten a robot he's out there just
throwing and he has no feel for the game
he has no rhythm bill walsh talked about
rhythm and timing and all those things
Blake doesn't have any of those well
Coughlin's got to see that right
Coughlin's knows it I mean look I see it
every I mean I'm not saying I'm smarter
than anybody else but it's been obvious
for two years and the crap that I hear
well you know Blake was coming back I
mean ESPN put that graphic up here so
you know he was had a good year it was
junkyards it would be like me leading
the NBA in rebounding because I get all
the missed free throws they don't count
nobody can test missed three throws in
the NBA get eight of those and you got
eight rebounds a year right at night
like Bors was getting yards he's never
been able to get first quarter
touchdowns he gets behind and he gets
all this yardage so stop looking at the
stats and watch the tape it's obvious 19
million dollars so ask him the poll
question Brockman asking the poll
question here yeah lombo who should be
the Jag starting quarterback Blake
bortles Chad heady Colin Kaepernick well
look I look I think Colin Kaepernick is
not a the issue of I have about Colin
Kaepernick as his play but he's better
than play portals like he's better than
Blake bortles I mean Blake bortles
doesn't really you could just see Blake
bortles his body language we talked
about Jay Cutler's bio language Blake
bortles body languages please rescue me
please somebody help me I can't do this
I can't I can't do it he can see there's
no confidence in him rich would you want
to get in a huddle with that like you
want somebody come in the huddle and say
look guys you got to protect we're going
to do the boob you got to have some
leadership skills last night I saw a guy
just barely hanging on so how do you
answer that poll question I would I
would sign Kaepernick I would sign
somebody I answer to my question is he's
not currently on the roster if I'm that
if I'm Tom Coughlin today I'm trying to
trade for Brett Hundley I'm trying to
see if Jimmy Garoppolo can they can pry
him loose a deck that won't Haley I
would try every you really think that
the Jaguars today could pick up the
phone and call Bill Belichick and say
what do you got for me well I mean they
practiced against them they watched
Garoppolo play it was pretty obvious no
no no this is nothing to do with
Garoppolo resume this has to do with
whether Isabella not all the stops to
say like what and why would New England
on the end of the season want to give up
the body other words I'm not trying to
throw a fire I'm saying I would make
every phone char possible
I'd call Brett Hundley I would find any
way I could solve this problem because
the one thing I do know for sure the
answer isn't in Jacksonville I like I do
I like Chad Henne but I just don't think
Chad Henne is going to be able to do it
I know bortles can't do it so if I'm if
I'm Tom Coughlin I've got to have some
way to do it and he did it
Tom's done this before he took Mark
Brunell fifth round draft pick that Ron
Wolfe turned around and gave him to him
for a third-round pick I mean that made
his franchise Tom knows what he has to
do Michael Lombardi of the ringer here
on the Rich Eisen show why did you laugh
audibly when I said the rams could be
the sleeper team in the NFC office
because that's the only person they're
sleeping with his is Luca Brasi there's
no Chad there's no chance they're
sleeping with him oh they're they're so
bad red fishes thought everybody saw
look I love Shawn McVeigh it's a great
story 31 years old
okay belcheck when he was 31 was it was
a dead linebacker coach of the Patriots
when Greg Popovich was 31 he was
coaching out of Pomona pit sir when when
Pete Carroll was 31 is a defense
coordinator of NC State okay
it's just a hard job it's a really hard
job Henry Kissinger said this in his
memoirs he said when you go to
Washington you borrow on the
intellectual power and you can't bring
it when you're there being a head coach
is the same thing you come into the job
you can't renew your intellectual power
you've got to be ready to be a head
coach when you're 31 I'm sorry you ain't
ready you're ready to be a coordinator
you may ready to be a head coach so that
challenge plus Jared Goff first play of
the game first play of your Rams
preseason this year last year
it's called spacing they go out there
they run spacing it's a play that
they've run a zillion times right he
throws it in the dirt I mean at some
point you got to have a feel for the
game he doesn't have a feel for the game
they're going to keep going down the
bortles road to break it off you can
already say that about Jared Goff right
I'm telling you Goff has no feel for the
game he has no feel for it it's all
manufactured Pro short pass last night
bortles they were trying to get him to
throw short passes so they can get some
confidence in them like he would never
and then when they had to throw it down
the field he under throws it by three
yards I mean that's bortles though
you're saying golf is is anything that
he played a place in the game does
anyone needs reps if anyone needs reps
in football it's Jared Goff you can't
get those reps back
and who would be the NFC sleeper team
and by that I mean a team that that
didn't make the playoffs last year maybe
a top-10 drafting team that can actually
take a step forward like the Miami
Dolphins last year like the Detroit
Lions last year that step forward to put
themselves in a playoff mix I thought I
thought well Tampa fits that category
they didn't make the playoffs last year
they were picking 19 well close there's
other hot dogs from November I think
using last night that's where the real
football team looks like if I'm David
Caldwell and Tom Coughlin and I watched
Jameis Winston I'm saying that's what a
real quarterback looks like but that's
what we don't have we don't have that
that's pretty so it's right in front of
you that's what we don't have uh you
know I think that in the NFC you can't
choose Carolina because I mean well no
because Carolina's got some nuclear I'd
back me just watching can throw today on
ESPN the clips they're just at practice
he just doesn't look right yet it's
gonna take a little bit of time for him
to get that shoulder back and feel
comfortable with it because it to give
you some time to think this is my way to
tap-dance a little bit yes you can think
of your NFC team I'm choosing the
Chargers as my sniper team in the AF I'm
with you on that I would sail in that
boat with you because they they were a
team that was out of it last year and
they can really take several games
better than last year's record steps
forward this year and do some damage in
a division if not maybe scare some
people and have a chance to win that
division I like it that I'm not seeing I
don't see that team in the NFC that's
why I've been Brockman you said that
last hour am i talking my way into a
sleeper team in the NFC you know if I'm
gonna go San Francisco I I think they
look I think would Kyle Shanahan did in
Atlanta this fight out remarkable I mean
if you look at Matt Ryan's numbers from
his career to what he did last year you
if he was a baseball player he'd be
being tested for steroids because it's
remarkable the difference that he had I
don't mean that it I don't mean that in
a bad way I'm just saying that there's a
such a variance in his numbers that it
was remarkable I don't know if Matt Ryan
could ever have that kind of year and I
think Kyle Shanahan's a great coach I
think Kyle Shannon is a great coach and
I think Kyle Shanahan's ready to be a
head coach and I wouldn't underestimate
the 49ers at all I think he's got Brian
who are playing well
even though like playoffs well I think
here's what I do I do know what in arms
here's what I do know about the NFL
schedules matter and the West plays the
south so the NFC West plays the AFC
South so you can collect a lot of wins
if you're playing Jacksonville if you're
playing in D who's not very healthy
if Houston is the best team by far in
that division I think everybody has
Tennessee as a sleeper team I'm not
there with Tennessee so I think somebody
could steal a bunch of winds from the
AFC South or from the NS o ulama Niners
as your NSE sleepers if you had put a
put a gun to my head I figure if we
figuratively I like to I like the Niners
I like Kyle Shanahan I think he'll do a
good job that's a Michael and party in
the Honda inside a rapport and again
it's brought to you by the 2017 Honda
Civic and available turbocharged engine
we love the Honda Civic 42 miles per
gallon on the highway I mean this is a
seriously efficient car and it looks
great and it would look great in your
driveway go into your Honda celebration
sales event right now and score yourself
a great deal on the Honda Civic back in
60 seconds I want to talk with you about
Andrew Luck I want to talk with you
about how you think you can beat the
Patriots it's a great article you wrote
on the ringer that's Michael and Barney
a national treasure he is back in 60
seconds pressure monitor that DirecTV is
your leader in 4k Ultra HD and it's the
first u.s. pay TV provider to bring you
live sports in 4k channel 104 s
dedicated to 4k with movies
documentaries and audience network
content 4k is four times the resolution
of HD and it's the next best thing to
being there DirecTV is your leader in 4k
Ultra HD we've got Michael and Bharti
back here in studio from the ringer and
you wrote a great piece in the ringer
well you're right I guess that's being
redundant everything you write it's it's
great up for Simmons is ringer about how
to beat the Patriots yeah not how do you
beat the Patriots minor Lombardi you
know as Rocco was rocco told Michael and
too difficult not impossible but I do
think you have to have an institutional
commitment to the special teams I think
that's really but I don't think people
really understand it and I'll do a
shameless plug for this book I'm writing
but the book I'm writing I'm talking
about special teams and I'm talking
about really great coaches in this
industry build their culture in the
building through special teams the
culture can be created through special
teams because of this if you want an
all-in mentality and you want to be
everything once to resonate with every
player being part of the team and do
your job which is a trademark of the
Patriots how can you create that if you
don't have everybody participate in
special teams and that's where the
Patriots get their get their ability
Bill Snyder at Kansas State
do you realize since 1935 I think it was
Bill Snyder has won more games from 35
till the time he got there because he
emphasized the kicking game he built his
culture on the kicking game same thing
Don James did at the University of
Washington same things that Urban
Meyer's done at Ohio State and every
place he's been so if you want to beat
the Patriots institutionally you have to
be committed to the kicking game it just
can't be love we gotta have it we need a
good week of practice in the kicking
game this week is that why John Harbaugh
has more success yet against New England
than many other coaches because his
background is special teams because they
are very good in the kicking game and
they work at the kicking game and I
think you have to be able to control
field position on Brady look the Super
Bowl that the Giants won the one in
Indianapolis the best field position
they had in that game was their own 29
yard line
Steve Weatherford didn't get it didn't
get the vendee P of the game he deserved
it he was the difference in the game he
had four punts while you're talking my
language if you want to talk about
punter is MVP exactly Mon know I mean so
so that part is look you've got to be
really good in the kicking game and
that's what I wrote about and I don't
think people really understand it like
I've been around too many coaches head
coaches that just want clean exchanges
and that's just snap to just skip get me
the ball back so I could start running
my office okay and there's this hidden
yards like you like glass drives me
crazy I scream at the television and my
wife tells me to shut up but I'm
screaming when we go to commercial break
and there's a flag on the field in the
kicking game right
well those flags that change his field
position so instead of your starting the
ball at your own 40 let's say now you
start at your own 20 that 20 yards
doesn't show up anywhere it just
disappears but it's hidden yards and
those hidden yards cost you games
against the page alright so strong
kicking
what else you kiss thing that I believe
and it's called la love a version you
have to not lose first before you can
beat the Patriots so you can't turn the
ball over you can't have mistakes you
can't have self-inflicted wounds like
making penalties false starts you got to
protect the ball no penalties in the
kicking game you've got to make them
beat you you can't beat yourself which
means you don't turn the ball over you
don't do something stupid so if you can
do those things that gives you a better
chance kicking game the law of aversion
don't beat yourself and then you've got
to make enough plays in the passing game
you've got to be able to convert those
four down play that's four-point plays
when you get the ball in the red zone
you've got to be able to score
touchdowns you can't kick field that's
that's why you call it a four point so I
called the four point which I don't
understand the NFL I wrote this in the
column the NFL is the greatest marketing
business of all time and we don't
emphasize four-point plays like the but
it's third and six at the Patriot and
you're getting ready to score it if you
miss the third and six you're kicking a
field goal we should have like lights go
off it should be sponsored by Johnnie
Walker red in the red zone this is a
four-point play so you could say that
the plays that that the Falcons ran in
Super Bowl fifty one after Julio Jones
catch we're seven point plays a sense of
employed plays exactly right because you
know that game goes back to us very
simply it's like the movie if you saw
the movie founders about Ray Kroc when
he realized he wasn't in the hamburger
business he was in the real estate
business right it's the same thing dan
Quinn didn't realize his opponent was
the clock not the Patriots at some point
you've got to make that distinction in
the game man you're perfect for Simmons
you talk in sports and you're dropping
like we've already had a godfather one
it's reference to now so I guess now we
got to bring it back in which team is
the team in 2017 that fits this
description that can best be I think the
Houston Texans by far I'd like the
Houston Texans I think they have the
complete team to play the Patriots they
can play them the kicking game Bill
O'Brien knows that he'll O'Brien they
just have to get really consistent play
from the quarterback which they didn't
get from the heist last year another
reference to the Lufthansa heist Brock
Osweiler case I did watch in case
anybody didn't watch News convoluted
caper with
that's another Gloria the wig man money
is money so Ronnie's Rick Smith more the
wig man because he cultivated that caper
I don't know he I don't know he got away
from but he he got out of it but look
look if you just watch that game closely
I mean Dion Lewis makes two plays that
score touchdowns that's a really cliff I
swear I'll make some throws in that game
oh gosh it's a close game what an if I
mean you want to talk about hips like
I'm not there in games we all have that
it if quarterbacking play improves in
Houston they will be a complete
competitor for what about the Raiders
with Marquette King and sea bass that's
right that's your kicking game Derek
Carr can make plays in the in the in the
passing game yeah you've got a
disruptive force in Khalil Mac and you
saw what von Miller did to that New
England offensive line in the AFC
Championship game if the Raiders can get
Tom Brady on an airplane to the black
hole in one of the last Sunday's of
January don't you think that they've got
this I think they could score with them
rich I think the problem is the Raiders
corners don't match up with the with the
Patriots receivers they don't have a
laterally quick corner they don't have
somebody who can change direction on a
horizontal way and they have to if they
want to play a vertical game against New
England New England won't won't go down
that road the win will make them run
crossing routes they'll protect very
well I think it'll be a high-scoring
affair but the paint but the Raiders if
they don't cut that on their mistakes
they got to get better on defense I'm
worried about the corner situation in
Oakland their offense they've got a
bunch of blue chip players I talked
about it in my podcast they're really
good on offense and I think if they get
anything out of the tight end position
and Jared Cook they don't even improve
their office they can score with the
Patriots but scored with the Patriots as
the Chiefs found out and is every team
if you want to get into an ad a game
with the Patriots you know you're
probably not going to win that just like
when you play the Warriors in basketball
if you want to play up-tempo good luck
you're going to lose
so who's the Dan Issel in this equation
well they have the pay that was they
have to do Marshawn Lynch is the
dentist's on this one because if I'm the
Raiders I'm keeping I'm keeping Lynch
healthy for November and December and
then I'm going to utilize his skillset
to keep the ball away from the Patriots
and I'm going to utilize his ability to
control the clock and utilize his skills
Jack Del Rio is the Doug mo I'm not
going on their jacket down these old
Nuggets Road Michael Adams yeah let's
keep going Larry Brown
Larry anyway Michael Lombardi here in
the Rich Eisen show what's going on with
Andrew Luck shoulder best you can tell I
think I think Andrew Luck has taken a
beating and I think this is this is
something that Chris Ballard when he
took the job at Indianapolis he realized
that he's going to have to fix a lot of
things other than just the team and
partly what he has to do is is create an
offensive in a defensive front that can
control football games and lint and and
luck has paid a price for that
I mean luck has paid a severe price I
think when you look at it when you're
drafting receivers in the first round
Bill Walsh is to say this all the time
and people get mad at me because I'm
anti drafting receivers in the first
round
Walsh always said you only draft a
receiver when the rest of your team is
complete well Indianapolis kept drafting
receivers you know they have T Y Hilton
they got then they go ahead draft
first-round pick Phillip Dorsett who's
available and trade if somebody's
willing to talk to them about it right
now
right now you could have them if you
want them nice coming off a hamstring
but they know they need to get better
around luck
they need bigger receivers so they can
block when they spread the formation out
when you have two little receivers you
can't really run the ball out of that
floor and you're in spread you can't
really run it somebody's got to block
somebody and I just think that Andrew
Luck shouldn't play until he's 100%
health and when do you think that is hey
if it's in the first of October the
other thing I think it's really so go
the first month of the site would here's
what I we've got tolsey well good luck
but I think this here's what I think I
think the preseason in the NFL by the
rules and what's happened in the league
you have to extend preseason into
September because you just don't have
enough time to come on oh no I'm not
talk about preseason games rich I'm
talking about preseason perspective as
an executive because your team's not
right look
everybody's so obsessed Jared Goff
played eight plays right
what's he what is he slit by the way you
know this is all coming back to Blake
bortles yes we're just going to not know
anything no no life
I promise coming I promise you it's not
but there's you can't get enough reps in
a guy you can't get enough reps two guys
in the summer right because everybody's
trying to protect their team from
getting hurt and I'm saying is forget
about getting hurt you got to get your
team ready for the season you can't
worry if guys get hurt life goes on you
got to move on and I think that when you
try to protect your team from getting
eyes hurt you end up not getting your
team ready that's why September these
teams look so bad why do you think Miami
looks so bad last September they weren't
ready for the season
also at Seattle at knowing there's not
an easy way to start a season well you
got a prepare a team for that that's
right Mike Lombardi on the ring or at at
em Lombardi NFL and the ringer comm
check them out actually stick around one
more segment okay because Lonzo ball
versus Ben Simmons is a conversation
right now and I know you might have to
considerable sense on that being a sixer
guy and we'd passed on ball you sure did
okay let's read Mike Lombardi next here
on the Rich Eisen show
the number of days we are removed from
Mayweather MacGregor equals the number
of ounces in each one of the gloves that
they will be wearing eight eight days
removed now from Mayweather McGregor
which you can catch right here on
DirecTV pay-per-view 9:00 Eastern on
August 26 to order right now text the
word event 2 2 to 3 3 to 2 or go to
direct tv.com
it's available in HD on channel 123
standard def should that be your bag on
channel 1 24 and please don't forget to
weigh in cast your vote tweet at Rich
Eisen show using the hashtag mayweather
FTW or mcgregor FTW on twitter to tell
us who you think is going to win I ask
the question yes Michael Marty you need
DIRECTV to get that fight oh yeah it
would be helpful but can you order
through DirecTV yes you can order
through DirecTV didn't you just hear my
idea but I'm eating you know I was well
done I just I was not but I was
wondering and honestly I'm like unfrozen
caveman lawyer when it comes to outside
of the DirecTV realm on how to get this
I understand I don't know what terms
you're using what I don't understand
what you mean I'm like the unfrozen cave
I got it now I'm very clear things going
to win that since you're Iraq on tour
you're a man of about I don't think May
were there I think anytime somebody
tries to change sports it's going to be
a little difficult okay
I think you figure the only guy I mean
you're come on now rocky come on oh god
no I mean I look up he's like the Irish
Balboa there's such a thing that the
familiar right well yeah right Thompson
wrote a great article about a woman yes
for the magazine I learned a lot about
him in that but I'm still going to go
with Mayweather
okay what is the you there was a news
item you were going to mention about
Lonzo and Ben Simmons right that there's
a there currently even though yeah the
odds for NBA Rookie of the Year they're
currently even long ago and and Ben
Simmons what do you think well you know
I mean I would say ball probably will
beat them because knowing the way the
76ers medical staff Lee keeps players
from playing all the time if I only play
30 games it out to being a fan over I
just it just annoys me you want to be a
mentally tough team and then you rest
every player like how do you be mentally
tough if you rest players you know the
resting of players I think are over
because the league is going to start its
season in the middle of October and
they've gotten rid of the four games in
five nights to five games in seven
nights there's no excuse anymore
there isn't any especially young players
need to play yeah like Jared Goff needs
to play like young players need to play
and I just worry that the 76ers are so
conditioned to resting their guys and
they love to put guys all he's got a
hemorrhoid he's out for three weeks
sitting and I trust in the process and I
don't try I'll never trusted the process
so I'm gonna go with ball I'm a fan I
look out look I'm a die-hard I mean they
pull me back in process it but at some
point I keep saying they got to hit the
win it now but now's the time to hit the
win and now but yeah I hope they hit the
win it now bright JJ reddick is a nice
addition to for one year that I won year
twenty three million was was good I just
think to me they have to do something
over fur like they have nothing like
there's no plan for him and he's not
going to be able to play very well they
need to get to turn that into something
else
now speaking of Philly Eagles Chris long
is about to join us on the show how he
longed was on earlier this week and had
this to say about raising Chris and the
rest of the long family in
Charlottesville Virginia I was shocked
and horrified you know you have to
understand Charlottesville
Charlottesville we it is as fine a place
to live with as caring giving a group of
people as you could find and for that
kind of hate and and if that kind of
device Ennis to be present in your town
for people to be injured one young lady
32 year old woman lost her life and I
think that's the age of our oldest son
Chris and it's just horrible this is
going to join us after throwing his arm
around Malcolm Jenkins last night during
the national anthem he's a good dude Det
Chris tremendous family gathered us all
of a wife Diane does it mean why how he
keeps you know if she deserves all that
yeah deferring all the credit I mean
really the thing I always think about
when I think about that family is that
Kyle was a pitcher at Florida State
could you imagine that guy on the mound
no could you imagine like getting ready
to face his left-handed let me go when
you say Samardzija would be similar to
that I mean it's not the same size as an
offensive lineman Samardzija but Anthony
Munoz was that way to it usually we've
got about 45 seconds left do you want to
just throw one last elbow or Blake
bortles before you
okay look I don't hate Blake bortles
what I hate what I hate Richie is I hate
not admitting a mistake I think that
that's part of life and you have to
learn like I'll middle must sit here and
tell you all the ones I've made you make
them I mean that's the only way you're
going to learn but I think what they're
kidding themselves down in Jacksonville
they're kidding themselves you know they
don't wake up today and say you know
what we got to get this fixed we got to
get a quarterback in here somewhere
somehow we got to work the telephones
you know look AJ McCarron call Brett
Hundley do something you're gonna join
us on each week in the phone right look
forward to it absolutely Lombardi
Wednesday's coming
Rich Eisen shows half so excited well
thanks rich Lambeau you are the best
thank you save me a spot on the beach in
the Jersey should well we're done the
private model thank you sir Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking